foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__] this
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
hey up sucker
Rudy Giuliani loses his defamation case
this morning in a ruling
Federal courtroom
Hellboy
ow so much winning right oh my God just
there's gonna be so much winning
remember when we were told that that's
been so long ago that there's gonna be
so much winning
ah Rudy colludy Grandpa farty mcsharty
America's felon
I think it's like eighty nine thousand
dollars is what he's ordered to pay
um
in impunitive sanctions
to shamos and Ruby Freeman
which to be honest if it is 89 000 is
that's the amount that's not near enough
being threatened by the president and
his lawyers
and then having the manga supporters
threaten your life they have to move
they probably will no longer be election
workers they should be
it's more of the game to see our
election speaking of stealing our
election in news there's an Alabama
Alabama representative
Republican
who has been indicted on and I think in
the last two elections there was another
there was another person I think in
Indiana convicted of voting for Trump
twice
in the same election you know he'd go
from jurisdiction to jurisdiction voting
for Trump twice hmm I wonder where the
election fraud comes from I wonder where
there's election interference hmm I
wonder what it could be I wonder if it's
all projection from Maga in the right
could it be could it be that they are
lying to us could it be that Donald
Trump is lying to us
ah you can't make this [__] up I don't
know why I'm laughing about it it's
really not that funny but you can't make
this [__] up
even to try to write a really good
comedy right a really good comedy a
dramedy maybe we were talking about
dramedies yesterday maybe writing a
really good dramedy
where you'd have a reality TV show star
become the leader of the Free World and
then try to become king of the Free
World
you couldn't hardly write this [__]
but Ruby Ruby Freeman and sheamos you
remember them from the January 6.
um
select hearings
and their story
and how that story projected into the
American political discourse
and why why the January 6th select
committee was doing what they were doing
not not just because of January 6 of
Donald Trump trying to steal our vote
but to show you that they were willing
to break the law
commit felonies
to do anything and everything they could
to have the narrative that it was stolen
from them as they were trying to steal
it
and Ruby Freeman and sheamos were caught
in the middle and the reason why is
because they have tenacity
because they're Patriots and they
wouldn't bend to the will of people
telling them to say what the what they
wanted them to say
and when Ruby Freeman and sheamos
wouldn't do with the Trump campaign the
the
Kanye West PR person
when they wouldn't do what the [__] they
wanted them to do they tried
intimidation tactics to get them to go
away and despair their name
and it didn't work
Ruby Freeman and sheamos are going to be
known as Patriots
which they are which all all legitimate
election workers and I say legitimate
because folks if you believe that
there's Republican election workers out
there that aren't attempting
to try to to try to skirt our usurp our
democracy by being an election worker
you're out of your [__] mind at this
point
they went to the Capitol to violently
try to overthrow our government you
don't think they're going to quietly try
to commit a coup as being election
workers
oh Tony take your tinfoil hat off oh
okay all right well just wait just hide
and watch and you'll wait to see the
[__] criminal convictions of these
people
it's gonna happen
they're gonna they're going to try to
steal the election in 2024 they're gonna
try to do it
and they're gonna try to do it right in
your own Precinct right in your own
backyard
but Ruby Freeman and sheamos will be
known as American Patriots
and they will go down in history as as
women who would not bow to Trump and his
[__] lies
Patriots
they stood on their oath and the
Constitution not his fragile little
[__] ego
and that's that's the truth and they
were defamed
and had damages because of it and the
judges ruled this morning that that is
the case I showed you a clip the other
day of Rudy Giuliani outside the Fulton
County Jail whining and crying bitching
and moaning about how a reporter
was lying about the fact that Rudy
Giuliani had to say no
no I I
I did lie I did lie about Ruby Freeman
and sheamos we were telling lies
we were spreading lies about them we
were defaming them
and the reason why is because he
wouldn't give discovery
and the reason why he doesn't want to
give discoveries because there's
felonies hidden in there that's the
[__] truth
that's the truth they can't give up
Discovery because there's felonies
hidden in there we know that now why do
you think why do you think
funny Willis is so hell-bent on
Prosecuting these [__] in
Fulton County
why do you think that
she could she could lay her case aside
and let Jack Smith do his his thing
they overlap so much those two cases The
Fulton County case and election
interference and the January 6 case in
Washington DC where Trump is indicted
those two cases overlap so much that she
could just let Jack Smith take care of
that
there's two black women
is the reason why she's not I believe
because Ruby Freeman and sheamos don't
just deserve the defamation that a judge
gives them they deserve the justice that
was done to them in Fulton County
these [__] boneheads went to Fulton
County to try to steal your vote and not
just the people of Fulton County because
they were going to use it as a catapult
to go around the entire country to steal
your vote and if you don't think that
then you don't know how Republicans and
Nazis work
you're not paying attention
if you don't believe that
because even if
Trump pressured the Secretary of State
or Ruby Freeman and Shea Moss
to make up some [__] story about how
it was stolen from Trump spreading lies
if they would have done that
they would have went for state to state
to state and say see they're lying for
me see they're lying for me you should
be like you should be lying for me too
they're lying for me Rudy Giuliani tried
this [__] in Arizona
with Rusty Bowers they tried it in
Arizona
Jesus Christ they had a fake state of
electors in Michigan 16 of them are
indicted in Michigan on felony charges
it's likely that this could open up a
case in Arizona Bonnie Willis's case
this criminal case that is hopefully
goes to a speedy trial oh my god listen
I I totally underestimated Bonnie Willis
and I was all for her I really thought
that she was gonna Hammer these
[__]
oh man I really I really thought Bonnie
was gonna just get these some [__] I
mean you think Jack Smith is a bad
[__] Bonnie Willis doesn't give
two shits about Jack Smith I actually
probably think Bonnie Willis has told
Jack Smith and the United States
prosecutors where to [__] go
because you damn sure know that those
Federal prosecutors do not want Bonnie
Willis to go before them
you damn sure better believe that that
is how the system works that is how
these prosecutors think
that the feds go first because the feds
are Almighty especially as special
counsel and Bonnie Willis doesn't give a
[__]
and she's like you know what fine you
want to do a speedy trial let's do it
[__] I'm ready to convict you on every
single one of these felony counts
foreign
I don't know it looks like it looks like
Bonnie Willis is going to be willing
to sever each one of these defendants
out of the the overall RICO case
to prosecute him think about what that
means for a second think about because
Sydney Powell and cheese Pearl are out
of their [__] minds they're not
they're not all there all the screws are
not tightened
and there's a few that are loose and
gone
all right this whole [__] Hugo Chavez
thing and the [__] Italian space
lasers and cheese burrow being at the
Insurrection it's all [__] nutty
nuttier than squirrel turds as a matter
of fact
so they're not all there so I have to
believe at first I thought all this is a
delay tactic but somehow Trump has got
the cheese burrow and and the Kraken
can't even believe that the Kraken
release the Kraken and we're not talking
about how [__] nutty she is Jesus
Christ this was the person they had at
press conferences talking into
microphones as they were trying to steal
the election
huh anyways I digress from that I guess
I figured cheese burrow and Sydney
Powell's attempt to get to a speedy
trial as fast as possible with some sort
of attempt
to delay and how you would imagine that
is that Bonnie Willis would say no I
don't want to sever these these
defendants I do I want to try the all 19
all at once
which would have prolonged the process
and maybe that's what Folly Willis want
but when she saw their [__] Bluff she
called it
because she appears to be calling their
Bluff that let's do this [__] let's try
this tomorrow
because she totally understands the uh
the jury selection process in a case
like this where there's so many
defendants
she's going through one right now I
think her jury selection uh in the RICO
case she's in right now and court has
been nine months nine months they've
been selecting a jury
So the faster she gets to selecting a
jury the faster she'll get to an actual
trial
but she calls their Bluff
which again is it's not surprising
listen I I know a lot of fragile white
men out there especially if you're
haters in the chat aren't gonna like to
hear this
so just buckle up for a second you
little [__] in so [__] and let me
tell you the cold hard truth
because that's what we do here is cold
hard truth whether you [__] rank it
or not
the future of America
the Future Leaders the policy makers
the people who put our country forward
who clean up the mess that white men
have created for several hundred years
are gonna look like Ruby Freeman and
Shea Moss
they're gonna look like fonny Willis
that is the future of of America of
American leadership folks
and that's what they're terrified of
oh there's they're terrified I mean you
know there's these 19 people are
terrified that funny Wills Is Gonna lock
them away in a Georgia Penitentiary
that's no [__] joke
no one no one wants to go to a Goddamn
State penitentiary in Georgia
no one
but funny Willis is what the leadership
of America Tish James is what the
leadership of America judge chutkin
Kamala Harris
this is what the leadership of America
looks like
in the future that's what it should look
like
to be perfectly honest with you
there's no harder resolve in this
country from a demographic than black
women
they're pretty goddamn tenacious
and if you're looking for tenacious
leadership
and resolve and vigilance
that is the demographic that has
experienced a lot
to have that tenacity
and to stand against the power and speak
truth to it
just like Bonnie Willis is doing
and this little defamation case because
it is a little defamation case in the
grand scheme of things I mean if it
truly is eighty nine thousand dollars
that's not near enough as far as I'm
concerned
now Rudy Giuliani doesn't have eighty
nine thousand dollars
[__]
I couldn't even do a better guy it
honestly couldn't have happened to a
better guy think about this for a second
Rudy Giuliani in an attempt to defend a
lie about Donald Trump winning the
election in 2020 and his attempt to try
to help overthrow the government and
overthrow our vote
spent time and money as a attorney right
and I use that word Loosely and I know a
lot of people don't like when I bash
attorneys but look the farther we get
into this Trump thing the more I think
look if to be a good attorney it's
really hard but just to be an attorney
it's not that [__] hard to be a
lawyer quote unquote have you ever
listened to Alina Haba
or Christina Bob or Rudy Giuliani or
Sydney Powell it's not that [__] hard
to be an attorney folks it's not that
hard if you want attorney on your
business card it ain't gonna be that
difficult to be one it can't be
but think about this
he spent his time and billing hours to
try to help Trump steal the election
and now he has to pay the legal fees
I'm Ruby Freeman and Shea Moss
and Trump ain't gonna give him a [__]
dime how in the [__] don't these manga
idiots see this [__] I'm not talking
about the lowly [__] that are
mortgaging their house to give Trump 500
a month so that he can pay his actual
legal bills because he has to defend
himself in four criminal [__] cases
and God knows how many civil lawsuits
from here on out
about the people
something
I mean Rudy Giuliani could have just not
did that whole coup thing
and he probably would have plenty of
[__] money
he can apply to be a foreign agent and
represent as some sort of security
consultant that's what he was doing
before Trump became the president if you
remember
using his America's mayor again he's
America's felon now the mug shot mayor
but this is the story of the Trump World
Jesus Christ look at look at Mike
Lindell
look at the my pillow Nazi look at this
[__] he was at the White House
folks
with papers
to tell Trump how to overthrow the
government you remember that he was
standing outside the Oval Office
the my pillow guy was going to go in the
Oval Office and not because Donald Trump
thought to seek the advice of the pillow
guy that wasn't what it was
he knew the pellet guy had Deep Pockets
and that guy was willing to spend every
[__] dime of it in the name of Donald
Trump and is still doing it to this day
and still doesn't see how he's being
duped because he's a [__] loon
he doesn't see how he's being duped by
Donald Trump
good [__] him
[__] Rudy Giuliani [__] Sydney Powell
[__] cheese girl [__] my Glendale [__]
them all
every last [__] one of them they're
getting exactly what they deserve
every [__] last bit of it
this is this is their doing to
themselves [__] them
Rudy Giuliani did not have to go on this
Rampage around the country trying to
convince lawmakers and states to
overturn their election illegally
committing felonies Time After Time
After Time especially after prominent
Republicans in these states you can't do
that you gotta have evidence
where's the evidence
and even even when was pushed back by
Brad rathus Mathis pathysburger and his
deputy
who told Donald Trump and his campaign
and Mark Meadows which by the way he's
broken the Hatch Act at this point and
he's admitted it on the stand because he
said he was working in the capacity of
Chief of Staff when he wasn't it was
campaign lawyers on that [__] phone
call the perfect phone call he was using
the the the chief of staff on the office
of the chief of staff to try to overturn
the election and help the Trump campaign
and it's breaking the Hatch Act
not that he'll pay a price for that
think about it
think about where we're at in this
timeline
think about all the [__]
[__] that Donald Trump has put these
people through
now
go back and think about the debate that
just happened just a week ago just a
week ago
it was a week ago tonight
every [__] one of them bastards stood
up on stage and said if he's a convicted
felon they raised their hand and said
they would support him Chris Christie's
kind of like well I I didn't actually
mean it I mean kind of sort of I mean
you know Chris Christie's gonna support
him folks
he's gonna say all this [__] about him
and at the end of the day Chris Christie
is going to be at the Republican
National Committee convention and he's
going to be standing there being
interviewed well you know I I believe
that Trump yes some flaws he has he has
some definite flaws and he's done some
things that probably aren't uh Copa
shetting but uh he's much better than
Joe Biden
that's what it'll be
bet
[__] hide and watch doubt me if you
want to I don't give a [__]
I'm just telling you the truth that's
why Chris Christie's hand went up
cause they're [__] a cult and they've
been a cult for a long time I'm not
talking about my I'm talking about
Republicans
all around the country
every single [__] last one of them
who's voted the last 40 years for a
republican just because they had an R
next to the name
they are or were a member of a cult
100 percent
well let me ask you just to prove just
to prove the point
just to prove the point if Anthony
Weiner run for president
would you vote for him
would you vote for Anthony Weiner
running for president would you would
you do that
because he's a Democrat you know
is Democrat
Anthony Weiner was a damn good
Congressman too
he's a [__] scumbag a [__] creepo
and he does some weird [__] online
would you vote for Anthony Weiner would
you do that
because he's a Democrat
you wouldn't would you vote for Hunter
Biden to be a United States Senator
because he's a Democrat
you wouldn't do it
you wouldn't
you wouldn't do it just because he's a
Democrat
they do it all the time and will
continue to do it
that's the [__] threat
it's a cult
and whenever I hear you know the media
is starting to come around to my way of
thinking on this whole Donald Trump's
going to be the nominee thing I don't
know have you noticed that
it's almost like there's producers at
MSNBC listening to the show
and I welcome you if you are great
fantastic keep getting the message out
there
keep doing that
because it's that's going to help
instead of your dumb [__] message
where oh we'll just like we'll just let
Jack Smith save our democracy that's
what we'll do
Jack Smith is not going to save our
democracy folks
we are
but they're starting to come around to
my way of thinking about Donald Trump
being the nominee have you noticed that
are you have you been watching the media
like MSNBC CNN but MSNBC especially
they really figured out what I figured
out in January well really in December
there's no way Ron DeSantis is gonna win
no [__] way
and there's no one else standing in
Trump's way no one
vivec is not gonna win
Chris Christie not gonna win
as long as that fat [__] slob Donald
Trump is still alive come the Republican
National Convention as long as you know
because you know he's hard his heart's
got to have problems by now don't you he
looks like [__] have you noticed that
God damn he looks like [__]
I mean you know
91 felony indictment counts
that'll give you a little bit of blood
pressure stress you know what I mean and
all that hate that he holds oh my God
the constant [__] bitching and
whining and moaning can you imagine how
much that age is a [__] can you
imagine
oh man he's got to be at least 103 in
stress years by this point
that fat slob
okay
six three two fifteen shut the [__] up
that ain't real get the [__] out of here
uh Rudy Giuliani Donald Trump
Two of a Kind two of a pair gross sick
old [__] and Rudy hey man
little piece of advice for you if you're
listening it's it's time pack it up go
to Jack Smith
go to fonny Willis Cut A Deal do a
little bit of time
in a federal prison camp maybe the rest
of your life but a little bit of time in
a federal prison camp and just give it
away just show them show them exactly
what happened just do that man it's it's
a disgrace your whole your whole you put
Mobsters away you were the America's
mayor that's all [__] done man it
your your reputation all that stuff you
did it's all destroyed no one gives a
[__] anymore Rudy they don't give a [__]
I don't know if you can tell or not but
we don't care what you did in the
[__] 80s and 90s we give a [__]
though
about being held held accountable for
how you tried to [__] steal our
democracy and help help [__] the
Cheeto dust cueing on her become king of
the United States you [__] piece of
[__] don't go anywhere we'll be right
back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show if you want to
get your very own party blanket that's
right they're [__] real
they're real
it was just an idea but now they're real
go to the store not I am Gabe Sanchez
that's store.im games
com some
parent gets your very own pardon blanket
they exist they're real
please be real these be real or you can
go to the Tony michaels.com scroll down
to Gabe's merch store the link is there
go to the Tony michaels.com also while
you're at the Tony michaels.com follow
us absolutely everywhere
YouTube Facebook twitch wherever you can
follow us wherever you can give us
support give us support there
if you want if you want to get in on a
venmo chat there was a few yesterday
venmo super chats
um if you want to do a venmo super chat
that link is also
on the Tony michaels.com
well let's see here let me get that uh
let me get that let me get that in the
chat
here Gabe Sanchez is going to be joining
us here soon
I believe so I think so he's got he's
got a what was that about Rudy Giuliani
that he wants to show us today uh so
we're definitely gonna show that so he
might join us live he might join us via
the what was that we're gonna do that uh
someone someone said in the chat here it
was Evelyn here's on YouTube says yes
MSNBC Joy Reed
is listening to you Tony she follows me
on Twitter so I don't know if she's
listening to me on Twitter and she's got
producers listening to the show I'm not
really sure
um which it is but a lot of people have
been sending me clips of MSNBC Lawrence
O'Donnell the Joy Reid some others and
they've been saying hey they're starting
to say the [__] you're saying and been
saying
that's why you guys are ahead of the
game
you know that right when you see
something and you're like oh yeah [__]
we've known that for three months
it's because I'd been saying it for
three months it's not that difficult
right so like and I I know I beat this
drum a lot but
it's a drum that has to be beat here uh
before we get into the uh general
election cycle next year it's very
important
it's very important that we beat this
drum
very important
that we get this [__] straight oh
another one another one that's been sent
to me was Ali velshi I believe he was
filming in like gun for Rachel or the
11th hour or something like that that
was another one that was sent to me uh
Ali welchi another clip that was sent to
me Ali Bell she is like a machine over
there at MSNBC
he like he's on air for like eight hours
live he does way more um live coverage
than I would ever dream
oh boy boy boy boy I'm big step fan says
Lawrence O'Donnell doesn't blow smoke up
our asses either
he does the best to tell the truth yeah
you know
truth tellers sometimes
um aren't the most popular folks
right because uh you could you could
like when you when you have an audience
you can like just appease the audience
and that's what I accuse a lot of folks
a lot of the commentators of doing when
I do it they're just appeasing the
audience they're telling them they're
saying out loud what they think the
audience wants to hear that's what the
right does all the time
like that's what they do that's how the
delusion [__] perpetuates right
it's how delusion perpetuates
is you just continue to tell people the
[__] they want to hear even though it's
not the [__] truth
or it's [__] that's probably not gonna
come to be the truth
when you're realistic about things and
you're like you know this is all cool
and stuff but that's just not how it
works and that's not how it's gonna
happen because this this this and this
and you're forgetting all those things
to make what you want to feel that would
be great to have happen happen
because there's a lot of things I want I
don't want anyone in this country to
have a to go broke because of a medical
bill
I want that I don't want anyone to have
anything but a decent [__] wage if
they're working
no one everyone should have a decent
[__] wage and if a company can't pay
someone a decent [__] wage then they
don't they don't deserve to be in
business
in our capitalist Society period period
if a business can't pay their workers a
decent [__] wage they do not deserve
to be part of our capitalist system they
just don't [__] you you can drown if you
can't pay people
I I you know some of my favorite places
I wouldn't give a [__] if they were off
the face of the Earth
if they couldn't pay their employees a
decent [__] wage
I don't I want people to get educated in
this country
and I want them to get educated that's
best for them
and not have to [__] sacrifice their
entire life in debt because of it
I want people to be able to two of to
afford living
to have to have the ability to have
Leisure Time
that's what I want it sounds oh man it
sounds radical doesn't it oh my God Tony
wants to make sure that all Americans in
the richest country in the world
have like you know the bare necessities
of a good Society oh my God how dare I
but sometimes sometimes folks on the
right the left whoever moderates
Independence whoever they don't have a
really realistic idea of how that comes
to pass right they just don't
they make up all kinds of [__] in their
minds of why it should be a certain way
negating things that are real negating
reality one of the Prime examples is
Medicare for all you remember that [__]
you remember that [__]
now I'm not saying I'm not for the
policy but the [__] message was dumb
as dog [__]
it was [__] even the Democratic party
wouldn't buy that message do you
remember it
do you remember this
I mean this is a prime example
of how messaging is everything even in
the Democratic Party
it's everything
it means everything it is the first line
of defense in politics and elections is
your narrative
Democrats a lot of times are shitty at
it the left is horrible at it
horrible free college you remember that
[__] free college you remember
and remember remember uh you know
Joe Biden wasn't gonna [__] forgive
student loans and he tried and it wasn't
it wasn't the moderates that stood in
the way it was the [__] fascist right
that stood in the way of that
one of them is a United States senator
now
he used to be the Attorney General of my
state he brought the original lawsuit
Eric Schmidt
he's a senator he's a piece of [__]
trash that guy oh he's a [__]
horrible piece of garbage I mean he's a
republican so what do you expect
but the narrative is everything and if
you if you expect if you expect that the
media isn't going to have the right kind
of narrative to perpetuate democracy and
to defend it
because they're like oh man we're
supposed to be non-biased non-biased
what the [__] are you talking you are in
the Constitution it says it right there
free press it says it
it doesn't make bones about it it
doesn't beat around the bush it says it
right there
you are part of Defending democracy you
are our front line
the media is the Press is our front line
and they have forgotten that
because of advertising dollars
do you see us have any corporate
sponsors here
on on the podcast we don't we're
supported by you guys 100 this show is
supported by the people who listen to it
and the reason why I don't have any
corporate sponsors and I can't get
corporate sponsors especially at this
point
is because I don't [__] appease an
audience
I won't do it either I am not gonna
[__] tell you a bunch of [__]
that I know just is not [__] true to
make you feel good
that's not the intent that's what we
should not be doing
that breeds delusion
and delusion breeds disappointment hard
just like just like Medicare for all oh
man what a great disappointment
oh America wants once Universal Health
Care there's another stupid [__] word
Universal Universal it's really dumb
shouldn't use that word anywhere ever
not in a tweet not you shouldn't say it
out loud like it's a good thing
you just shouldn't
because the right did a really good job
of making that word bad and it is now
bad
sorry it's just it just is
and they did a damn good job
at destroying the phrase Medicare for
all
you remember what happened
remember none of them were really for
Medicare for all just Bernie you
remember that and then Elizabeth Warren
she was like rising in the polls Bam Bam
Bam Bam she was called man Elizabeth
Warren
Senator warrants coming up in the
running she's gonna be the nominee and
then she said Medicare for all
and she Tanked
Joe Biden never said Medicare for all he
said what we're going to do is we're
gonna go off the ACA and we're gonna fix
the ACA we're gonna make it better
that's what he said
anyone
because of that
if Bernie would have never said Medicare
for all and he wouldn't have said the
free college [__] if he never would have
played that messaging and that narrative
he might have beat Joe Biden
all you lefties out there
who love Bernie which I'm not against
Bernie I don't know if you know that
hell most the time I agree with Bernie
on almost every single policy point
I just don't like his narrative
because it it's [__] it doesn't work
it works in Vermont but it doesn't work
nationally it just doesn't sorry sorry
to disappoint you but it doesn't work
that's the cold hard truth that's the
[__] that if you like Bernie and you
don't like when I say that that's
because you don't like the truth you
want me to say something that makes you
feel good but I'm not going to say it
Bernie's messaging and narrative
nationally sucks it's horrible because
that's not what people out in the
country want to hear
you can say the things that you want and
say the truth
and you don't have to say it a certain
way
do you guys ever see me quote data or
polls ever do you ever see me talking
and very rarely am I like the Wall
Street Journal reported The Washington
Post reports this morning
I don't do that
there's a reason why I don't do it
I don't have to do it
so why do it why
oh but Tony it reinforces
this is whoa it reinforces
your point reinforces my point
that's what the f word is about man
but this is this is really why this is
really why
I don't have corporate sponsors
because I won't I won't Bend to the knee
and say the things that you have to say
to appease an audience so that the ad
buyers feel good about it
I won't do it
this is the reason why YouTube isn't
monetized because I won't do it
I feel it more important for you to hear
the cold hard raw truth
without a bunch of BS
and I get comments every single day in
both directions
some of you get into the comments and
you're like yeah [__] those guys tell
the truth [__] them
don't hold back
and I get the comments like man if you
just if you just uh say a few F words
less
just a few
I mean I've had people call me and tell
me to not use the f word as much and
then they'll say it like this like look
here's the thing
if you just stop using the f word for a
little bit just a little bit and you
just cut back on the cussing and the
cursing just a little bit and don't get
quite as you know crazy
you know crazy crazy
then what you can do is then you can
build off of that and then then you do
whatever you want you do whatever you
want
it's not about me doing whatever I want
that's not what it's about
it's about me doing it authentically
number one I don't want to have to
pretend to be someone else oh my you
know how taxing that is
to come on the air two hours a day and
to pretend to be something that you're
not why do you think all these right
Wingers are such that look like [__]
they look like hell
and they have to constantly to be
defending their authenticity because
they're not authentic it's all [__]
most of these right-wing commentators
know Trump lost they know he's a [__]
box they know he's dragging their entire
party in their entire movement down they
know that but they don't have a choice
because the audience has to be appeased
prime example is Chris Christie right
he's not trying to appease an audience
well look what he's getting nothing
in return he won't receive anything
actually he's
actually he's being he's being funded by
some Democrats if you want to know the
honest truth
just to drive wedges down in between
Republicans to break this up
um a lot of people are saying we love
you just the way you are don't change
I'm not going to
trust me I'm not going to
um Andy says can you imagine if Howard
Stern didn't remain himself on the radio
keep it real Tony so that's a good point
because I've been compared to Rush
Limbaugh a lot because it's politics but
if you go back and you look at Howard
Stern's career Howard Stern was not
always Howard Stern
he was pretending to be someone else for
a long time and then he became authentic
Howard Stern is authentic now that's why
a lot of people hate him
a lot of people have hate Howard Stern
now because he he's changed I mean you
get older you change you're kind of your
mindset chain your experience changes
right
because everyone has their own
experience
that's why I never that's why I never
questioned someone else's identity uh
their their gender their sexual
orientation
right where they're from I never try to
question that I mean
I'll mock you if you're being really
ridiculous about it
right like these two-way Bros are like
oh yeah these goods are for our rats
which is all [__] they didn't
believe that [__] 30 years ago 20
years ago even really even 15 years ago
they didn't believe the way they believe
about guns now that's all fake it's all
[__] they've created a narrative
that is not real
by lying and posing and pretending
there's something that they're not like
tough guys and [__] you know I mean like
JD Vance holding a gun to shoot the the
the the the Chinese spine balloon you
remember that [__] poser
[__] poser JD Vance would get his
[__] ass stomped in a bar fight
get his [__] ass kicked in a bar
fight no question
that is how it would work if JD Vance
got into a bar fight he would get his
[__] ass kicked
it's a poser he's tending to be
something that he's not
well the media is full of posers
they're full of it
they're full of they're full of [__] and
they're feeding you full of [__]
now it doesn't make them the enemy it
does it doesn't mean that we we should
get rid of the media we should just call
them out and make them do their job
better that's what we should do
we should say yeah you're full of [__]
you're full of [__] [__]
my friend
I like you you seem smart you seem like
you can rub some ideas together with the
brain cells that you have
but why don't you do it with a little
bit of Truth and reason and logic
instead of shoveling Us full of what we
want to hear
because you know that's what Maga does
they just go look for what the [__] they
want to hear and once they find it bam
it's the truth
and as soon as soon as someone tells
them they don't want to hear fake news
fake [__] news
fake [__] news that's like a lot of
people been getting mad at me
because I I I'd say I think someone bit
me
in the comments section the other day on
one of the on one of the episodes
bet me like a hundred dollars I think
they wanted to bet me a hundred dollars
then I would um
then I would it is weird
that I that the trial would start on
March 4th they wanted to bet me a
hundred dollars
because I was saying it's not it's not
going to start on March 4th
and it's it's not I hate to I hate to be
the bearer of bad news
but whoever it was who bet me a hundred
dollars I'm not gonna bet you 100
because I I mean I don't want to take
your 100 hours in a bit
cause I'll win
just like remember remember several
weeks ago and again I keep pointing this
out but several weeks ago oh the whole
internet Twitter left Twitter was like
ah cameras in a courtroom
foreign
televised the trial you remember that
[__] oh yeah they were all saying it
maybe they've all deleted those tweets
but they were all saying it guess who
wasn't saying it me because it's not a
thing that can happen it wasn't going to
happen so why would I give you a bunch
of [__]
why would I shovel a bunch of [__] down
your throat and frankly it takes me time
to to go against that [__]
it takes our time to sit here and rebut
the stupid [__] narratives
that are coming from the left
when they're not [__] gonna manifest
stop doing that [__]
stop it stop
if you want to create narratives create
narratives that breed confidence not
delusion
that would be great and that's all I'm
saying you know a lot of people like hey
Tony we can be vigilant and want Donald
Trump to go to trial next year yeah I'm
not saying that I'm not saying you can't
be
I'm just saying don't get your [__]
hopes up for this guy to be sitting in a
prison cell or Rudy Giuliani for that
matter next year
you know Rudy Giuliani lost his
defamation suit but this doesn't mean
he's going to be hauled off to a [__]
jail cell tomorrow
and Rudy Giuliani is going to have the
right to a speedy trial or he can wave
his right to a speedy trial my guess is
is that the judge in this Georgia case
is going to allow any of those
defendants to sever
from the 19 to go to speedy trial on
that date
I believe that's what's going to happen
and here's the thing
if Sydney Powell or cheeseburger which
are the two big names right now that are
wanting this speedy trial thing I think
their calculation because their screws
are loose their nutty and [__]
squirrel turds I believe
at first I thought it was some kind of
trump tactic but I believe they actually
think they're going to win
I believe they're so [__] delusional
they're so out of their [__] minds
that they're gonna win this case and
they're gonna win the speedy trial the
best part is they're not going to they
are going to catch and be convicted on
several of these charges if they do this
which will be good for funny Willis it
will be bad for all the defendants who
still have to go to trial don't you
agree Gabe Sanchez I mean to some degree
I mean we talked about this when this
first happened we were like it seems
like a tactic maybe it's a tactic I mean
I think I think it is here here's here's
what it is it is a tactic done by them
in an attempt to Great like if I get it
done quickly like maybe I'll be able to
beat them in court because they don't
have the documents or the ads oh they
definitely think they're going to beat
him in court yeah
but the problem with that is they're
like great we already have 19 of you
under this whole conspiracy and we have
all these other individual charges as
well
so if one of you wants to go
then we're ready for all of you and
there's no excuse for any of these
people to have to delay any further so
they're like hey we want a speedy trial
I want a speedy trial she's like you
know what great this is and and I and I
said this on on I think it was last week
or the week before I said this on the
call was like you cannot tell me that
phony Willis and her team did not have
multiple different paths to go forward
because they knew
if they decide to delay then we can do
this if they Delight if they decide to
uh to accelerate the trial they'll do
this if they decide to sit complacent
and not do anything just go forward
they'll do this like you can't tell me
that after two years of investigating
these crimes that her team is not
prepared because she literally said in
her press conference this is not
basically in so many words she's like
this is not my first rodeo right we have
gone after so many different people this
is uh you know hundreds or so cases that
we've already gone to under this exact
specific crime
so this is not the first time I'm going
after this this is I I come with
experience my team is experienced we
know what we're doing we've been
investigating we have a grand jury we're
ready to go when they are and we will
determine a date that is best for
everyone
and cheese bro [__] open Pandora's
Box because he was like well let's just
do it in a couple months and they're
like okay let's see who else has to do
that and then you know Sydney's like oh
I want to do that I want to do this like
great you guys did exactly what we
thought you would do you thought that if
you sped up the trial that would be like
oh flustered not thinking it would
actually happen but surprise surprise we
knew exactly what was going to happen or
we were prepared for one of the
potential paths that you wanted to take
and this is what's happening right now
they [__] themselves over because they
thought they were smarter than the
people who were coming after them and
again you do not
you should not underestimate these
people Jack Smith phony Willis Alvin
Bragg Leticia James like none of these
people
should be underestimated they're coming
with years of experience
and expertise and actual intelligence
and every one of these trumpers like
well you know what I'm a lawyer well you
know what to be a lawyer Now isn't it
from your standpoint right no it's not
well here's the thing is to the to the
speedy trial thing
because you know Donald Trump
is fearful of this and the reason why
and the reason why is because if phony
Willis does take a handful of these
[__] to speedy trial she's
gonna win a number of these convictions
if not all of them yeah something
there's something called like I don't
know precedent right so once they have
that exactly and you know what I I
there's one other thing I want to bring
up everyone's like oh my God this is so
political this is this is uh election
interference because it's the day before
super era you know the election day on
on in March right well okay one
first big thing if if every one of these
trumpers including Trump and the other
18 defendants that are in this Rico
investigation if you're innocent then
you should have no problem going to
court to prove your innocence two
if you're so afraid that this is
happening the day before an election
then you should be all for having it way
before the election right well the other
thing too is because they're like this
guarantees he's gonna win so why are you
why are you [__] scared then if it's
gonna guarantee wins then you should be
cheering this but we know we know where
election interference comes from and We
Know It here's another [__] report
this morning listen to this one
news morning a legislator from Alabama
is facing voter fraud charges this after
investigators accused him of voting in a
district where he did not live oh crazy
Madison County jail records show that
representative David Cole of Huntsville
is facing charges for vote can you can
you guess can you guess what uh
representative what they say
representative [__] here apparently
can you guess what party he's a member
of can you guess I mean if I just if I
had to give you one guess
if I had to if I had to pick like one
letter out of the alphabet of 26 letters
right probably go with some it's like in
the later half of the alphabet right
um definitely not in the beginning but
in the later half of the alphabet right
it's like um is it after the LMNOP that
thing element yeah okay okay yeah
there's like a big cue and then R yeah
that's the member yeah he's a republican
let's continue voting in unauthorized
locations the arrest comes after
accusations that coal did not live in
The District in which he was elected oh
crazy Colt was elected to the House of
Representatives last year the charge is
a class C felony which could mean up to
10 years in prison the Alabama attorney
couldn't have it wait wait wait wait
this guy was just put into office that's
right okay now
I'm just gonna say uh there tends to be
a pattern this this is never like oh I
just did it for the first time there's
always going to be previous crimes that
this person has done whether or not it's
specifically with an election fraud or
voter fraud
they're gonna they're gonna probably
this is not their first time they did
not wake up on Election Day and say you
know what I'm gonna go vote in a
different area and then go vote in my
area and no one will be the wiser
I have to assume that this person has
done crimes previously you know she's
become a criminal overnight you don't
just decide to vote twice in an election
oh come on you think you think this guy
has been has been a a criminal I think
he's a Serial
voter fraud like Captain Crunch or um
cereal cereal are like Jeffrey Dahmer
Jeffrey Dahmer Captain Crunch time uh
well I mean depends how how harmful
these crimes are but I'm gonna tell you
right now there is no way that this guy
decided on that day he was like oh you
know what I've played it fair my whole
life there's no reason I should do the
same thing no the guy's been doing
illegal [__] for years this is the first
this is not the first time that he's
ever voted twice and this is definitely
not the first time that he's committed a
crime so what makes it worse is the fact
that this guy was like I'm gonna become
an elected official and I'm gonna be
able to influence my power and
manipulate things and the Republicans
and the Republicans like this guy is our
guy this guy who commits election fraud
that's who we want being our
representative God so dumb but hilarious
right there's another there's another
um a story out there about
um another Republican who committed sort
of the same felonies I'm looking for it
though
well I mean there's a lot of Republicans
who commit felonies right now it's
really hard to distinguish I'm sorry uh
for you know casting that that wide net
there yeah but here's the thing is that
they I believe was in Indiana he was
sentenced to I think five years can you
see if you can find this he was
sentenced to five years for voting twice
uh in the same election for Trump in two
different I think in two different
polling stations but it was in it was in
2016 and 2020 that he did this and he
was finally he was finally sentenced
yeah I told you this [__] doesn't happen
once right well I mean I mean look look
at the look at the uh um what is it the
villages is that what it's called yeah
five years they have the highest
concentration of voter fraud well so far
so far so far so yeah I wanna yeah we
gotta give that caveat so far hey you
know what I'm just noticing trying to
look for this Derrick Evans you always
tell me you need to screenshot tweets to
quote tweet so that way if they get like
suspenders them apparently he's
suspended Twitter suspend to Derrick
Evans Free Speech right I wonder what he
did was he charged with a crime
he's been to prison for Trump and still
supports Trump which is kind of nuts to
me
um and I would show you some of his
tweets this morning that I was tweeting
back at him because he said just [__]
[__] box
um then I would I would show you but but
I can't now because his account is
suspended I'm looking for this case they
were sentenced recently a woman
sentenced to any oh I got it I got it it
was it was it was a man it was a man
there's a woman too Victor Indiana man
sentenced over five years in prison
yeah yeah
I think that's I think that's it no no
no no no no no no different
no this is a different this is different
fraud this is a different this is
different Republican
[Laughter]
uh oh my God
it never ends with these [__] though
right man I still love the guy who
killed his wife and his mother-in-law
and then voted for them oh in
Pennsylvania yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I love I I always love to use that
example when someone's like man voter
for it and I'm like give me one example
well there was just one time no that was
made up let me tell you about the guys
no that that shit's that shit's fake let
me let me tell you about this guy oh all
those dead people voting you mean like
the people that manga kills and then
tries to vote for them is that what you
mean by dead people voting you mean what
you mean when Republicans cry out about
dead people voting and illegals and
multiple votes for one person and going
to other places to get other people to
vote on behalf of you know it's like you
do realize that you're just describing
the Republican party right now right
people you do realize that Republicans
told people in The Villages hey go vote
twice if you got a mail-in ballot vote
then and then vote in person that's not
how that works guys it's one or the
other you can't do both you could take
your mail-in ballot bring it to a
polling station but you can't send in
one and then walk into one and then
submit your ballot you [__] idiot so
um why why you're looking for this
sentence of um a voter a manga voter
frauder uh let me show you uh someone
else who's being sentenced or tried to
be sentenced this morning
um for seditious conspiracy thank you
dude he's [__] getting shanked in the
shower man well that might be
um but the alert was from Scott
McFarland that the judge was out sick
so this morning this morning Enrique
tario was supposed to be sentenced and
the prosecutors I believe are asking for
like 33 years I believe it's over 30.
um boy that's that's a shame well you
know you win some you lose them right
you [__] around you find out right but
this morning Enrique Tarios uh
sentencing has been rescheduled to
September 5th on Tuesday uh so we'll
probably be covering that as that news
hits but it's because the judge was out
sick a lot of people were spinning
theories but Scott McFarland has it here
um that the judge was out sick per the
U.S Marshals so they weren't able to go
ahead with the sentencing and possibly
up to 30 years
but here's the thing we were going to
lead with that until the story kind of
fell apart there well yeah um but you
know it happens I want to show everyone
though why we're talking about that why
you're looking for the other one do you
you know how Enrique tario looks like in
his proud boy [__] where he's got the
ball cap and the [__] sunglasses the
sunglasses and the flak jacket and the
[__] tight t-shirt and all that [__]
oh he looks like a badass right [__]
bad [__] let me show you what
Enrique atario actually looks like this
is what he actually man that's some
[__] ass [__] [__] yeah well it
happens this is what Enrique Terrio
actually looks like
um this is what happens to people who
break the law who try to commit sedition
who try to overthrow the government
and I I do want to point something out
about this uh
I'm sure you've noticed
you've got people like Jim Jordan and
other people you know on the Republican
party that are trying to
sugarcoat the crimes that uh that Trump
is being charged with uh in various in
various investigations
um or indictments that he's received
but they're like oh I can't you can't
just like call someone and do this or
you can't like
commit this crime it's all you know
they're trying to downplay it to be like
oh it actually wasn't what you think it
was it was just him making a phone call
oh you can't just call someone to look
into something it's like no that's not
quite what happened and you know that
but Republicans are trying to downplay
every single crime as if it was just
like a a misdemeanor like I was
crosswalking right or I was jaywalk jay
walking yeah yeah sorry I was jaywalking
and
it's interesting to see them do that
with all the oh this person can't though
I've I just can't do this thing now
everything's gonna be illegal now it's
like no you know exactly what's going on
and you know exactly the crimes that
were committed and you know that they're
serious but right now you realize that
your party is losing because it's
attached itself to the boat the ship
that is
trumptanic and you guys are [__]
breaking and half and going down right
now and you're committed to going down
like a captain of a ship
when some people might jump out like the
rats and other people might decide that
they're going to go down one of those
people is [__] Rudy Giuliani that
guy's so committed to Donald Trump he is
so there's there's such a um and I don't
know people know this but the history of
Donald Trump and and Rudy Giuliani like
goes all the way back to the early 2000s
uh where he ended up going to Mar-A-Lago
after he lost the 2008 Republican
primary nomination or and and he ended
up finding himself
indebted to Donald Trump because he was
the only one who would take him back or
take him in
um into his political movement is what
you're saying well in into his realm but
then when 2016 came around he was
pivotal to be right there and then 2020
and then here's 2023 and we see what's
happening with Giuliani which I just we
should watch that but I just did a I
just did what was that and it was like
[__] perfect timing yeah well let's
well let's let's get to the what was
that the first thing I want to show is I
I guess uh Chris Christie speaking of uh
Trump and his legal woes and Rudy
Giuliani being uh Trump adjacent to the
illegal activity that Trump has
committed because this morning it's so
funny because this defamation lawsuit
literally Rudy Giuliani was supposed to
be paid by Trump to go do these to go do
these Dirty Deeds as his attorney and
now remember it was all a handshake deal
right that's what it was well you forgot
the small hand because there'd be a
small hand and then Rudy giuliani's hand
I'm just saying right that that's more
like yeah that's like that handshake
right but here's the thing is that Rudy
Giuliani was supposed to be paid for all
this work and the legal work that he was
doing for Trump for Trump to steal the
election right and now not only did
Trump not pay Rudy Giuliani now Rudy
Giuliani has to pay 89 000 in legal fees
well that's no no so this is I heard you
talk about this in the beginning okay so
did I get this wrong did I get this
wrong you you have part of it wrong so
the 89 000 is already due so that's why
when that number came up today I was
like wait this is already decided back
in July what happened was uh Rudy
Giuliani has not paid okay but he was
issued he was issued he was using the
sanctions sanctioned to pay 89 000. and
he was told you have to pay this right
now
he hasn't paid in a month and a half I
wonder why he hasn't paid it could it be
that he doesn't have it right and so
something I I kind of briefly touch over
because I I couldn't give all the time
to it but like one of the parts in the
what was that episode is that it talks
about in July Rudy Giuliani did confess
he was like look I lied I made this
thing but he also tried to spin it like
he didn't lie because we when I
mentioned that I think last week where I
was like Rudy said
I made these defamatory statements about
them but I'm not admitting that there
was election fraud which they're like
you can't you can't do that that's
you're worthless they were tied and
that's what they're trying to do what
they're trying to do is region is trying
to go into court and tell the truth and
then he's trying to go out into the
public to the press and tell a lie right
and that's why it's like that's [__]
confusing because that's what he's doing
because you can't tell the truth out in
the public because he would lose all
support it would he would lose all sport
because he would have to say Trump
[__] lost I knew he [__] lost
there was no elect fraud there was no
evidence of it anywhere and we lied to
everyone so that's what he'd have to say
this is when you look at the timeline
you've got early July sanctioned has to
pay 89 000 in some change doesn't pay it
end of July he lists his home up for
sale in New York City for 6.5 million
dollars has not sold yet I don't think
it will sell for that amount he was
lucky to get half of that if three
quarters of that
then you also have to remember that at
the end of July on July 26th he made
this statement and it was an attempt to
be like look look uh okay fine we'll
deal with these the sanctions or
whatever I I'll pay it when I pay it I
guess but I will make I will I will
uh I will save face here
and I will make everything fine by
admitting that I lied about what they
did
and his Hope Was That by doing that he'd
be like great I don't have to worry
about this [__] anymore I'm good to go
I'm safe uh we can I can worry about
these things afterward and then
so since that point he hasn't stopped
he's gone a month and a half into
talking more he's digging and digging
and digging himself into his eternal
grave as Nosferatu and so what you have
here is a guy that won't quit because he
can't quit he's committed to Trump he
has to continue this well because he has
to keep he has to keep grifting Maga
because uh great Gracie says it here
says I don't buy it I don't I think uh
really has many snatch ways okay so
there's a difference and I want you to
understand this um about being cash
strapped and then being broke being
broke means you have no money no assets
you're done you're bankrupt really is
not bankrupt at this point that's why
he's trying to sell his condo in New
York because if he sells his condo now
he's got cash but he doesn't have a
house that's why the judge and that so
that with the big update today was the
punitive damages they're like you
haven't paid this money yet and you keep
saying this [__] and you try to concede
and while admitting to the fact that you
lied then tried to tell people you
weren't lying very confusing I'm just
going to tell you right now I'm going to
take your word and say that you did lie
which means you're liable for this you
owe 89 000 and now I'm opening the
[__] box here and saying that you are
now responsible for punitive damages
whatever they may be yeah yeah and it's
not it's going to be probably if I had
to guess
multi-million dollar settlement that's
going to end up happening or whatever
the decision is are you saying are you
saying that Ruby Freeman and Shea Moss
are moving to New York into uh
because that's the difference between
Rudy being absolute bankrupt and him
being cash trapped he's definitely
cashed uh uh I think LED Parnes has said
that Rudy Giuliani has been castrate for
years yeah um that it's it that that's
the one reason why he kept feeding off a
trump is because he was Cash strapped
and it was a way for him to keep going
and act like he's America's mayor which
he's not yeah he's not he's ruined that
he's he's the mug shot Mary's America's
felon now if he's anything and so now
they're now the judge was like look uh
we're also coming after your podcast
because I know you make money here which
I do I do slippers
in the in the episode but the judge in
this in this ruling was like look
you have to report your finances which
he has not done he's been like I don't
have the evidence I mishandled it my dog
ate it I [__] right whatever it is
whatever I gotta tuck my shirt into my
balls I'm not actually playing with my
wings
in addition they were like look you have
to report the finances also for your
Communications company the podcast this
and that like you have to give the
finances for these llc's because that
means he's does that mean he's gonna
stop doing the podcast
it's possible but I don't think anytime
soon because what he has to do is he has
to he has to provide the financial
documents for the for the podcast and
everything else he doesn't have any
speaking engagements really rarely if
any the last time he did he would
[__] pay him to speak the Republican
the Republican party because remember
there was that one where Rudy showed up
and he was it was like yeah
Trump
is that what it normally sounds like but
you remember the one where he went off
in that drunk tangent yes and is you got
it easy that's kind of a broad which one
but he's not getting he look he's not
getting paid the money he got paid after
becoming America's mayor after he lost
like 0.708 was when that [__] went
downhill and he wasn't able to recover
right what Trump came in was like he's
under my wing he even had to go overseas
and pretend like he's some kind of
security consultant and take foreign
money yeah wasn't exactly
um registering as a proper form
right exactly exactly well because he
was being paid to do all that by
somebody some dark money somewhere but
let's let's I'm gonna make an executive
we're gonna go to the what was that
original
loyalty to Donald Trump ends in Epic
failure here it is what was that from I
am Gabe Sanchez hey everyone welcome to
what was that I'm Gabe Sanchez Rudy
giuliani's long and twisted relationship
with Donald Trump has led to a karmic
irony with Giuliani heading in both
financial and reputational bankruptcy
and despite Giuliani being stiff by
Trump and then arrested for him Giuliani
just can't seem to quit Trump do I what
do you regret attaching your name to the
former president
am very very honored
to be involved in this case but before
we get into that make sure to like this
video subscribe to this Channel and ring
that notification Bell so you never miss
another episode Rudy Giuliani seen here
as the human embodiment of cartoon
character Simon bar Sinister Giuliani
has given us many Unforgettable moments
over the years marrying his second
cousin Four Season subtle Landscaping
hair dye meltdown covet farts Borat 2
The Masked Singer and now drum roll
please his mugshots oh God that drunk
creepy Goblin is so ugly Giuliani found
himself in Georgia for picture day
because he was hit with a RICO charge on
behalf of trump which makes his whole
indictment that much sweeter and when
asked about the charges on Newsmax this
is what Giuliani had to say is that even
crimes this is the first amendment
this is Free Speech it's my acting as a
lawyer
I have a right to argue for my client I
even have a right to exaggerate for my
client exaggerating for your client no
that is definitely not a thing I mean it
also sounds pretty illegal but also is
Giuliani implying that he was
exaggerating about the 2020 election
claims and that the election wasn't
actually rigged like they said honestly
who knows but you gotta love Republicans
doing interviews they truly say the
dumbest things while also incriminating
themselves at the same time why the hell
is finally Willis trying to charge you
with racketeering
because she's a politician and not a
lawyer not an honest honorable lawyer I
think Giuliani might be drunk again the
last I checked Giuliani was being sued
for defamation by Dominion for making
false claims about the 2020 election
defamation for falsely accusing a
ShopRite employee for assaulting him in
sexual harassment by his personal
assistants for 10 million dollars yikes
not to mention that as of July 2023
Giuliani admitted in court that he made
false and defamatory statements about
Georgia election workers Ruby Freeman
and Shane moss in an effort to resolve
their lawsuit against him so Giuliani
accusing fawnee Willis of not being an
honest and honorable lawyer is Rich
which is something that Giuliani is not
since he had to settle that lawsuit due
to his financial problems I'll touch on
his finances in a moment but let's
quickly talk about the karmic irony of
this whole thing Giuliani made his
career using Rico to go after the mom
when he was a U.S attorney and now he's
been indicted and arrested on Ricoh
charges along with Trump it's like
Giuliani starring in his own tragic
comedy where the punch line is just as
baffling as the setup which by the way
giuliani's RICO charge came right after
he claimed that he was going to get
Hunter Biden on a racketeering charge
Rudy my guy just give it up already it's
time to move on from your unhealthy
obsession with Hunter and Joe Biden why
are you so obsessed with me seriously
Rudy it's gotten really pathetic just
like your debunked election claims I
don't think I'm giving giving anything
away at least I'll tell you my strategy
I'm gonna follow Mark Meadows and file
as soon as I do the the uh uh the
arraignment I'm going to file a motion
for removal to Federal Court which I
would say
um almost virtually will be granted so
we'll be doing it in federal court will
we get an appeal right away if we don't
if it doesn't get removed and your
answer my answer is absolutely correct
we will show because the real the trial
is about the following did he believe
really that there was sufficient ground
to argue that there was a a crooked
election or Jitney and was he lying well
the fact is I know he was he believed it
and I did and many others and many
others did in fact about 50 American
people believe it in fact a number of
Judges who were in minority believed it
but we decided to get out of the courts
and go to the legislature so we get
these Witnesses out and the answer to
the last part of the question is yes
there are things we didn't present then
because over the next next couple of
years a lot of people did a lot of work
and have been able to produce more
witnesses than what I would call
scientific evidence that is very
persuasive no there is no new scientific
evidence that will corroborate his
claims of widespread election fraud no
it will not prove his innocence in
Trump's Georgia case and no he
definitely won't be able to get his case
moved to federal courts but despite
having a terrible legal strategy
Giuliani can't keep his mouth shut Rudy
what is the battle plan then you get
Colton Moore calling for a special
session and a member remember they
didn't call special session uh when they
should have back in December of uh of
2020. what what is the uh give walk us
through your battle plan
well you know this is going to to be a
very very concerted effort lots of
lawyers and you know that means lots of
ideas I'll tell you my simple idea first
we all got to get removed to the federal
court I had it I have to correct
Professor dursley was calling he said I
don't have a good chance because I'm not
a federal official the statute has a
second provision that covers agents of
federal officials specifically lawyers
so I am in the category to be removed
but at any event I think we get a
removal to the state court there's also
a a theory called pending jurisdiction
if most of the case goes to Federal
Court then some of those poor people
that have been add-ons even though they
might be not entitled to go to Federal
Court get pulled in on dependent
jurisdiction so I think we're getting
the federal court I think there we
should make an Omnibus motion to dismiss
believe it or not all of these cases now
I used out of colloquialism there there
are cases particularly from Supreme
Court Justice Jackson that talks about
polluted prosecutors and polluted
prosecutors fusions
that can lead on the due process to
dismissal of cases if there ever was a
case it fits Justice Jackson's uh
strictures it's this one and that's what
I'd like to see and I'll have to argue
that with lawyers who have different
views but I think one big motion like
that number one it may work number two
if it doesn't work Steve as you know it
educates
it gives great lawyers who will be
involved in this the chance to discuss
it and stuff like that can seep through
the censorship just because Giuliani
says things out loud on repeat doesn't
make it true and the same thing goes for
Trump and the rest of Maga so even with
Giuliani surrendering himself to fawnee
Willis in Fulton County and getting his
monk shot taken oh I'm sorry that mug
shot definitely doesn't get any easier
to look at anyway like I was saying even
with Giuliani surrendering he's still
trying to claim Trump's innocence as
well as his own and I'm fighting for
justice I have been from the first
moment I represented Donald Trump and
it's a man
who has now been proven instance several
times
I don't know how many times he has to be
proven innocent and they have to be
proven to be Liars
actually enemies of our Republic even
when people were destroying rights
sacred rights they destroy my right to
counsel my right to be a lawyer they're
destroying his right to counsel
it's not accidental that they've
indicted all as lawyers never heard of
that before in America
all the Warriors indicted yeah that's
because Trump's lawyers were also in on
the scheme to overturn the election
especially Rudy Giuliani here's a free
tip for Republicans don't break the law
and you won't have to worry about
authorities charging and arresting you
Donald Trump tells you this they weren't
just coming for him
or me
now they've indicted people in this case
I don't even know who they are
these are just regular people making a
normal living no these are not regular
people these are people who committed
crimes in order to help Trump here's
Reverend Stephen Lee a pastor who
stopped and harassed election worker
Ruby Freeman on behalf of trump once
again proving that we need to keep
religion the [__] out of politics you
know the whole separation of church and
state and here's trevion cootie Kanye
West's former publicist doing her best
Pennywise the Dancing Clown impression
she posed as a government official and
threatened Ruby Freeman and Sheamus with
jail time if they didn't confess on tape
that they rigged the election like I
said these are not regular people those
people are real bad but it's not like
Giuliani has any other choice he has to
commit to the bit or else he's
immediately admitting guilt in their
scheme how does it feel to be on the
other side of the justice system how
does it feel to be on the other side of
the justice system all right don't
interrupt me I'm making a statement I'm
sorry don't interrupt me oh Rico Rudy
thinks that he's still America's mayor
and not just a lying creepy drunk sexual
predator that has lost any and all
reputational clouds if they can do this
to me they can do this to you what a
profound and accurate statement again
Republicans think that this is some sort
of gotcha argument but it's really not
it's as simple as this if you commit a
crime then yes you should expect to be
held accountable for said crime as you
can see the party of Law and Order
thinks that they're actually Above the
Law and that they're the real victims in
this whole situation though I guess
Giuliani is kind of a victim a victim of
his own creation by establishing an
unconditional loyalty to Trump Giuliani
has been loyal to Trump ever since his
embarrassing loss to win the Republican
Presidential nomination back in 2008 and
now their unhinged relationship has
resulted in Giuliani having huge
financial problems for example Giuliani
and Trump had a handshake agreement
providing twenty thousand dollars a day
for the Giuliani team surfaces after the
election but surprise surprise Trump
never paid Giuliani I am truly shocked
if anyone goes into a deal with Donald
Trump let alone a handshake agreement
they're a [__] idiot Donald Trump has
a long history of not paying his bills I
mean it's pretty much common knowledge
at this point even his former attorney
Michael Cohen has talked about this
extensively history repeats itself and
in this specific case one thing that we
know for certain is that Donald does not
pay legal fees Donald doesn't pay fees
at all but there's a pattern to what he
does he will pay a little bit fall
behind pay a little more fall bigger
behind other Trump attorneys that got
stiffed by Trump include Sydney Powell
Kenneth cheese bro and John Eastman all
three of which were indicted in Trump's
Georgia case Giuliani got so desperate
for money that he even flew down to
Mar-A-Lago to beg Trump to pay him look
if I were Giuliani oh God that is a
terrible thought anyway if I were
Giuliani I might think about using that
insurance that he said he had on Trump
back in 2019. I mean I've seen I've seen
things written like he's going to throw
me under the bus right when they say
that I say he isn't but I have insurance
now if giuliani's Insurance threat from
2019 is serious well that's potential
blackmail and most likely an Ethics
violation however Giuliani is so
pathetically loyal to Trump that he'll
just continue to do the weirdest gigs
ever like making cameos with an Abraham
Lincoln filter Virginia
vote against
the man who Dishonored our past by
selling my bedroom
hundreds and hundreds of times to
Scoundrels or selling supplements on his
YouTube channel I keep taking this
you Democratic creeps you're not getting
me babes the key to living longer is
mixing your balance of nature with a
scissor
what the actual he's stirring
supplements with scissors knowing what
we know about Giuliani and his unhinged
sexual predatory behavior with this
former employee I'm afraid to know who
or what has previously touched
those scissors but if anything it is
very clear that Giuliani is using those
scissors to scrape the bottom of the
barrel for any company willing to
advertise with him on YouTube and on top
of that the guy is now desperately
trying to sell his home in New York City
for 6.5 million dollars good luck with
that this whole thing is hilarious and
well deserved for Giuliani but you know
who's having the last lap of this karmic
twist the very people Juliana used Rico
to put away the mob not only that but
according to veteran mob lawyer Murray
Richmond who has represented several
Mobsters told the messenger you can
quote me to say they're [__] thrilled
Richmond noted that half of these guys
love Trump they freaking love Trump but
all of them are almost unified in their
position of hating [__] Rudy I'm
thrilled that Rudy will now experience
what it feels like to be on the wrong
end of a RICO prosecution with the
mandatory five years in prison facing
him it's not just an ironic result but
it's a just result he was a horribly
dishonest prosecutor and the wheel of
karma is about to crush him nothing
racketeering what the hell is wrong with
you well that's all for me today thanks
so much for watching and feel free to
connect with me at I am Gabe Sanchez but
before I go I want to remind everyone
that you can support this show by
signing up for my patreon as a member
you'll get access to episodes before
they go public a live weekend show q and
A's and discounted merch just subscribe
go to patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez
what was that that's a good one you know
the best part
I've never seen Rudy stir anything with
scissors and something about it man
something about him stirring
what what is that did he is it like a
supplement it's a supplement dude
there's okay if people don't know this
the last two years all those screenshots
that you saw him with abs and stuff I've
been watching Rudy Giuliani make YouTube
ads for his podcast
and ah my God man there's two years
you've been watching this [__] two years
I'll I'll come in at one point he had a
show called Common Sense ironic
then he has another then he has another
show wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait was that his first podcast because
that was the first podcast we had to
abandon that because he's like no that
didn't make no sense so now so now he's
got another podcast which if I look it
up right now it goes by the name of uh
it's like America's maybe America's
mayor or something like that but I've
been watching him do these everything
from like home safety and my pillow
slippers and this is
slippers
when you when you look at uh his
behavior
America America's mayor
live is what it's called
America's mayor live so he's got that
show why did he call the first one
common sense though I don't I don't know
but a lot of it was happening after
after the election he was doing
The Common Sense Show and he was like I
got all the and I wouldn't be surprised
if those podcasts are going to be used
or have been used as evidence because in
there he talks about the affidavits he
talks about uh the crime all the
[__] all of it all it's all on
record so I mean if you look back maybe
you can find
uh he still has that show I'm sure he's
not yeah Rudy giuliani's Common Sense he
still has it up on YouTube so if people
wanted to watch him I well I'd say good
luck in going through that footage I've
scrubbed through a ton uh that's how I
found that one clip of him mixing the
supplements with the scissors with the
scissors man the best part is the best
part is it's not only is he mixing it
with the scissors because they're not
prepared at all yeah they're not
prepared then he he sticks the scissors
in his mouth that's oh my God that is
yeah it's pretty bad magic it's right
there so gross man the stuff I had to go
through to find certain footage I was
like [__] hey some of it I had
archived because I was like oh this you
know I'll use this I'll use this later
uh and then there's a ton there's the
teapot thing I didn't use that there's
another one where he's golfing I didn't
use that one there's just like so much
stuff but I only have so much time I'm
like all right well this that one was 12
minutes which is a little longer than
they usually are usually they're like
what under 10. and that's probably
because it was the clips of him talking
about right I got this plan with the
scientific evidence
scientific evidence can you imagine
going into a courtroom and you're like
so we need evidence and he's like well I
don't have legal evidence and I really
have evidence but scientifically yeah I
have and they're like oh that I guess
that sounds better do you have it with
you and he's like well I don't know
that's exactly that's exactly what
happened in every single case that he
went forward showing uh or trying to
show voter fraud in Georgia and then in
Michigan and Arizona and other places uh
I mean he's also [__] on that other
investigation too the one in Arizona
Rusty Bowers and Donald Trump I mean
like them trying to influence Russia I
think they're gonna get indicted in an
Arizona eventually yeah yeah they're
going to I think there was an update
that was talking about that but it's
like I think it's I think it's going to
be a Federal indictment not a state
indictment and I have Jackson Jack Smith
is going to bring a Federal indictment
against against Jenna Ellis and Rudy
Giuliani definitely if not Donald Trump
himself yeah um for I mean they [__]
themselves over I mean they they it's
truly amazing because I mean like you
know historically yeah people can get
away with certain things but they really
went they really went for it on this one
they thought that they could have the
whole [__] Kate and caboodle on this
and they didn't think that they were
gonna have anyone to question them or or
say that you have to you know uh
pay the consequence of the repercussions
of it you know they didn't think that
they were going to come to the to find
out phase after they [__] around right
and that's well I mean the more you [__]
around the more you find out as We Know
by the chart gay well you know um
speaking of [__] around and find out
here's what they do they just like their
go-to right now because we're getting in
this position where Trump is the we're
not even to Iowa caucus yet and Trump is
the presumptive nominee and really the
reason why is because after this debate
it was clear that no one's going to beat
him the media is now like oh hey Tony
was right no one's gonna [__] beat
him like I told you this long before
this like I didn't need to see the
debate to know that he was gonna this
was gonna happen but now they're on that
train right they're all like ah who's
how the hell is this gonna happen
anyways
um
but now that we're in a position of the
general election because he's kind of
the presumptive nominee and there's
primaries happening in they're blaming
everything
on Joe Biden everything is Joe Biden's
fault the fact the fact that Rudy
Giuliani and all these people went to
commit election fraud in the name of
Donald Trump at his Direction all of
that all of that is what Joe Biden did
that yes Joe Biden forced them to do all
this stuff and that's where we're going
to come down to is like we had to do all
this because Joe Biden I mean and just
listen to the Cheeto dust you and honor
here himself
um we've we used to play these more as
we gave Liz Harrington more and more um
I do you know I've been thinking about
these lately yeah and I've been
wondering
like because clearly Melania and him
don't share the same bedroom so he's
like do they live in the same house does
she live at Marlon well she actually
might live in New York honestly uh she's
like I'm getting Baron in myself the
[__] out of here
to be within 100 miles of that
[__] well I mean she also might
be like this I'm gonna take Baron and
myself and get the [__] out of here
right like she yeah I can't even see her
oh she yeah well she's a [__] box too
yeah she's terrible I'm not saying that
she's innocent I mean race members
terrible horrible piece of trash
plagiarizes just like Vivek Rama Swami
right right but hey do you think do you
think she eventually marries Vivek I
don't know it might be a good match I
mean don't worry she gets a she gets a
little I give her a little throwaway
line in the upcoming Vivek as long as as
long as uh you know when she Donald
Trump goes broke and she divorces him
Vivek apparently is almost a billionaire
a real one not a fake one like Donald
Trump yeah well you know so she could
she could go you know sugar daddy off of
it yeah that's true I'm just saying it
out she could she could leave him she
could be she could quietly be stealing
his money but the one thing I want to
say is these videos that Donald Trump
does
uh I wonder like when he's all alone at
night and he's got like some [__]
interns running the camera and he's like
well do it again we'll do it again one
more time and they're just running the
cares like nope I don't look great do it
again why do I look so orange yeah
let me tell you right now
I don't know why the color's so orange
hey what's that glass doing next mate
move that glass nope bringing that glass
back why am I orange okay okay it looks
good yeah it's the makeup it's the
makeup why is my makeup Orange has it
been this way the whole time but I'm I I
can only I can only imagine when he's
not on the road because there are three
moments where you see Donald Trump
he's here on camera mm-hmm
he's on the phone in an interview he
never does face-to-face uh interviews in
person but when he but when he
communicates right he'll never he'll
never like Street he'll never stream in
he always yeah but he's always on the
phone because he's [__]
you know so he's like I don't want to
look like that do that again wait do
that again how does it how does it go is
that is that what he looks like
that's uh that's impressive
more sugar sugar
um is that better
uh so there's three Moments One is when
he's on the trail I guess four one was
on the trail two when he's doing an
in-person interview with like Tucker
Carlson or Sean Hannity uh three is when
he's on the phone doing an interview and
four is when he's doing these videos and
that's really it you never see him ever
again maybe he might maybe he might like
slide into a Mar-A-Lago wedding well
every once in a while every once in a
while we get a photo of him golfing
right like he's out golfing so there's
people taking pictures of him golfing
but let's listen to this this is only 21
seconds uh bear with it you don't have
to listen to much of him
um but but listen to him crooked Joe
Biden is not only dumb and incompetent I
believe that he has gone mad a stock
raving lunatic with his horrible and
Country threatening environmental open
borders and doj FBI
weaponization policies he is a mental
catastrophe that is
okay thank you so much Donald now tell
me about Joe Biden tell me about anyone
else what the [__] are you I love I love
the projection you know what's you know
what's great about this is cult members
the the manga cult they watch this like
yeah
yeah and they're like I haven't watched
a clip of Joe Biden in weeks the only
thing I saw is on Reddit or on 8chan of
where he's kissing his grandson at his
at his son's funeral yeah and they claim
that that's some sort of [__] pedo
video like that's the only one they pull
out they don't listen to Joe Biden in
general like on a day-to-day basis what
he's talking about the policies
but the word salad oh my God
do you have ranch dressing for this word
solid Grandpa because God damn why
something open border d-o-j FBI
weaponization like what the [__] you're
just throwing out words now you're not
even saying anything dude
I mean you used to used to sort of make
some sort of yeah I don't know something
out of his [__] but God damn the
projection here though Stark raving bad
he's Stark raving mad
an irony man
I am irony man
oh my God this guy what a [__] [__]
show this guy is let me tell you
something I'm telling you dude he's like
all alone in Mar-A-Lago and he's got
like an intern or two that are working
the camera and making sure everything's
good to go I mean I wouldn't be
surprised if they're like
if he was like
okay am I good am I on am I is it
recording I don't see the red light I
don't see the red light red for a mega
Republican red just like the color of my
tie how bright is the color I don't see
it is it on and they're like yes it's on
he's like why don't I see it he's like
the Red's on my side and he's like okay
whatever you say what's your name again
and then all of a sudden
they're just like yeah you know what
just let this guy go just let him go I I
can only imagine there are hours hours
of Donald Trump going off on crazy
deranged unhinged rants that they said
was on camera
but they never actually recorded
um we I actually have a breaking clip
speaking of people who like to lie for
Donald Trump Peter Navarro apparently
um was outside a courtroom today so this
is going to be great now you might want
to make a note of this for what was that
I'm sure it's going to be in one
eventually I think the last time I did
one on Peter Navarro was last June yeah
no [__] yeah and that was when that was
when he was like I'm completely innocent
I'm gonna do this and I was like the
guy's going on TV and [__] admin [__]
it's a republican game plan that's what
they all do they go on TV and they admit
the crimes wait wait wait wait no wait I
never said that and you're like you
literally went on Steve bannon's show
and you said it well but they think to
some degree that that exonerates them
they're like no I actually went and
admitted to that so I can't be charged
with it I admit to it yeah like what
what the [__] are you talking about it's
like and it's ridiculous but here's here
is Peter Navarro outside the courtroom
apparently let's listen
this is kind of the importance
this is mocking the flag
but when it comes time for me
to express my view to you
even let an America
how dare she protest
how dare they protest oh my God it's
almost like someone else is the woman
the woman behind the woman with the sign
is supporting Peter Navarro that's right
yes she's holding an American and then
she Lo look at her orange hair right oh
my God this must be an orange orange
hair she's there and she's like I'm here
support Pierre Navarro the creator of
the Green Bay sweep the guy who tried to
overturn the election I'm here to
support another traitor to our country
because that's a goddamn Patriot a guy
who can't afford a haircut when he goes
into court and then the woman and then
the woman
also what is he wearing Air Force Ones
or like military boots those are not
dress shoes I'm not here to give him a
[__] wow you know run down Hey Hey
listen a lot of people like don't
fashion shame people or no that's what
we're gonna do no no no no no no I'm
gonna mock them okay if you don't like
it well then hit the button the fact
that that they're like oh he's
disrespect she's disrespecting the fact
she's holding up a sign if the woman
wants to be seen she can walk around to
the front and wave the flag in front
she could go to the door she could go
stand up on the side a concrete block
there she can go to the left of the sign
there are many ways but Republicans and
Mac would be like oh no I'm the victim I
can't do anything about this and it's
like you you could just move yourself
and you're such a [__] pancakes he
can't even just stand there and give a
statement not well he's easily triggered
what do you expect you know what it is
not a place to blame he's like no no no
no I'm not in trouble for the things
that I did to try to overturn the
election these are the real criminals
right well people here with the sign you
want to also know what I think it is you
know and also I think it is is that he's
found one person who supports Peter
Navarro just one that's the only person
on the planet that supports Peter
Navarro and he's giving her all he said
look at that megaphone that she's not
using right
right that she's not look at that sign
that's blocking the American flag man
I've seen I've seen trumpers do worse to
the American flag oh my God you know
what they did they used it to beat
police officers when they say back the
blue that's oh man
seems kind of we're going to talk about
disrespecting the American flag which by
the way we shouldn't be commercializing
or putting on merchandise if those
Patriots knew anything about the flag
they would know that they're not
supposed to do that but hey what who am
I here to be here with the [__] facts
you know what I you know what I say you
know it's one of the most American
exercises is when you protest your
government one of the most American
exercises is to burn the flag to burn it
that's one of the most American
exercises we can do that in this country
when we protest our country we can do
that we can protest our government we
can protest the people in it and we can
burn the flag doing it and there's not
consequences so get off the stupid
[__] American flag
some people are saying that the woman
with the orange hair
I could I could see that I could see
that
um
let's see I thought we had more news
here now there's a lot of news uh let's
see we got about 15 minutes left I'm
trying to decide if I want to go to the
Tennessee stuff or if we want to take on
that stuff tomorrow because there's a
lot of stuff happening in Tennessee
um if you didn't know uh Kremlin Cameron
Sexton was pushing and shoving uh Justin
Peterson last night on the floor and
then he gave some sorry ass excuse for
it and there's videotape of it so
there's that
um that I'd like to color but I don't
know if I want to get in the Tennessee
uh rabbit hole at this point with only
15 minutes left because really it's
probably going to take about a half an
hour to 45 minutes to really smoke that
out and more of it's happening like as
we're speaking yeah
um for the Tennessee stuff
um as it's ongoing there so
um I don't know if I want to go to that
but apparently there's a video of Mitch
McConnell yeah I was just gonna I was
just gonna send you that yeah so here
here is Mitch McConnell in a video I
don't know what's happening in it but
people are are saying there's something
that's happening is significant he
didn't get his he didn't get his update
is this is this glitchy michy again this
is uh glitch McConnell glitch McConnell
all right glitchy Mitchy let's watch
thoughts about what running for
re-election
oh damn
I I mean you know to be to be fair here
they did ask for if he had any thoughts
and he seems to be really
thinking about it I mean I just don't
like I honestly I honestly Wonder like
what the [__] like is this guy having
another like is he did he have a stroke
the first time again like what's going
on here again let's back it up if you
can't and I'll say the same thing dude
Feinstein man she gotta go dude well
listen there's a lot of these old
[__] that gotta go yeah yeah
yeah but I'm just saying like I'm not
gonna call only one side I'm gonna call
it both sides right
and she's also one where I'm like dude
can we get someone to replace well you
know interim death is at their door and
death you know uh they are they're going
to age out of not just being Senators
but off this earth eventually but let's
let's watch this again if you can't hear
listen the what the reporter asked the
exact question
running for re-election
oh what are your thoughts about running
for re-election in 2026 well he was like
he's like thoughts about what and
they're like running for reelection and
then he's like oh ho ho ho ho ho ho if
I'm still alive but watch watch as he
thinks this through
yeah what was that what was that Grandpa
did you hear the question Senator oh God
that's not a good no no that's not good
no that's not good no oh my God okay I
you know I wanna I wanna tell you
something because here's the difference
between this is crazy I had not watched
that clip and I was uh did not see that
coming you know um the only reason why
Mitch McConnell was still doing this is
because he he was one of the first
defiant voices in the leadership of the
Republican party when the when the big
lie came to a crashing [__] heaping
Fire Burning Fire after the State
Certified uh on December 14th of 2020.
he was he went to the floor to Mitch
McConnell's credit not to Liz Cheney Liz
Cheney took 190 days to do what Mitch
McConnell did
um and I believe it was December 14th I
believe it was that day or the next day
he went to the floor of the Senate and
said it's done it's over Donald Trump
lost the states are certified that's it
there's no more you can't say any more
[__] that's it it's done
um but Mitch McConnell here standing in
a way of all of as the establishment
Republican this guy is the [__]
minority leader in the Senate this guy
is supposed to be leading a caucus in
the Senate now Feinstein yes she's on
committees and [__] but she's not the
majority leader she's not in leadership
this is the Republican establishment
leadership folks
this is what is standing in the way of
trump some dude who can't even put a
sentence together
in the Republican party and you're
wondering why like everyone's ringing
the alarm Bells like hey [__]
they're not gonna do anything about it
Mitch McConnell the minority leader of
the Senate the highest ranking or the
second highest ranking Republican in
office Kevin McCarthy is capitulating
getting on his [__] knees wearing his
Cheeto dust knee pads to give fellatio
to Trump and Mitch McConnell's the only
other one standing in the way this is
this is the fight this is what you're
counting on
and you're and you're not gonna engage
in your democracy and pay the [__]
attention and not listen to what the
[__] the media says about any of this
[__]
this should be cause for your concern to
get your ass out there and do everything
you can to [__] make sure that we
slam dunk these bastards where they
belong in the trash in the [__] trash
because Mitch McConnell ain't gonna do
it folks he ain't gonna save you from
the fascist he is one by the way I mean
he's also there just to ride it out
before he goes
to his eternal resting place well let's
see if he does that on camera here I'm
interested to see how this plays out
there's like 20 seconds this is half
half it's still left okay I I like I
like how she's like close yeah oh [__]
oh God she's like this looks really bad
doesn't it who is this is this one of
his I don't know probably he's one of
his agents oh she's she's famous now
yeah well let's let's watch a minute
need a minute
oh God damn no oh [__]
he can't even respond to them
okay
[Music]
wow that was a slow reboot somebody else
have a question please speak up oh my
God that's not good either oh man man I
you know it was the secret that was like
his uh his you know security detail came
up and they basically were like are you
okay do you need any help like medical
assistance
and then he was just like
hmm
and then he walked away could you hear
if he made noise
maybe he's inside trying to yell do
turtles make noises like that they don't
they just kind of snap I don't know a
lot of people are like oh man you're
making fun of his health problems and
all this [__] hey you know what you know
what it's his problem it and really he's
making it our problem because he's the
he at least the least he could do is let
someone else be the minority leader he
could put soon he could say okay I'm
gonna step aside John thune that [__]
fascist that [__] [__] box he could
be the minority leader he could do that
because John thune would be would be
anti-trump I think as the minor I mean
that was so when was the last one last
month this month was it earliest month
the last glitch is that glitch yeah yeah
like before we had when he rebooted the
last time was that last month or this
one well I'm I the public reboot I I
don't know how many sure I'm not sure
how many times I have to unplug Mitch
McConnell replug him back in every day
but the one that you're talking about
August 4th yeah so it was this month
almost a month ago well let me make sure
hold on I'm seeing one month ago just
over three weeks ago
he is
no July 26th July 26th I said we're a
month so you know monthly update okay um
you know a lot of jokes are going around
about this and I'm you know Justin t
Brown a friend of our shows
he said Sub-Zero lead him again
hahaha
oh Justin you [__] oh [__] you
know what it's right here it's hard to
give a [__] that's two glitches that is
two glitches
we don't know what's happened in private
right the real question is what happens
in the third public glitch well I think
completely you're getting as a charm
type thing is that what you're saying no
like what I want to know is like do you
get like the blue screen of death and
you're like well this [__] hard drive
is totally gone or do you get like you
know you get a character upgrade or
something like Discord because when you
like comment and Discord you get like we
got a bot over there that's like oh
you're upgraded now to whatever well
he's it's level 36. you went down from
six to three so he's going down level
yeah I mean like really it's it's really
when you're playing a video game like
Mortal Kombat you hit by Sub-Zero and
the health goes down and you're like
teetering and it's like flashing that's
kind of what I'm seeing right now
I am I am curious like is this gonna
become a Weekend at Bernie's kind of
thing like are they gonna just like just
carry them around with sunglasses and
and try to excuse that as his vote oh
Mitch is here Mitch is totally here
committee's here Mitch is here to play
dude Sub-Zero wins I'm just
I just I just wonder I honestly Wonder
like all of these people Rudy Giuliani
that guy could have retired and been set
for life no problem but then he got
involved in more politics well yeah but
the thing is is they get they get so
[__] Drunk on Power I mean he's drunk
on other things too but for any for any
person and I know that you know like The
Human Condition and people can be like
I'm you know vulnerable to to influence
and power once I get it you know I I
want to have more and they get greedy
but I really look at these people and
I'm like man you you could have just
like left when you were at the the peak
when you were at the height of your of
your of your time or maybe like maybe
you dipped a little bit but you went off
on a high note and you had your money
you had your family you had the
remaining years of your life to go do
whatever the [__] you wanted but you
chose you chose to stay involved and
ride yourself your life your health your
friends and family your political party
into the [__] ground and that's them
that's their greed and their incessant
uh uh desire to want more and more and I
want more money and I want more
influence and more power and I want this
position
and I mean look at Donald Trump case in
point that guy was so greedy for power
and influence and such a [__]
petulant baby that he didn't want to
leave the White House that he caused
himself and everyone else involved who
were like I don't know if we should do
this he's like do it or you're done and
they're like I guess we have to do it
and now they're all getting [__]
charged with crimes and going to jail
well on the Mitch McConnell point
on what's Happening to him because
apparently we have an email from God
from the prophet Julie green we've
played her a couple times here on the
air but apparently we have an email from
God about Trump indictments and she
wakes up still [__] early to do this
[__] no dude 6 42 a.m which means she
probably woke up at like maybe 5 30 got
up showered did her hair did make up
eyeliner earrings in got her thing
turned the lights on and then at
whatever Point she started recording
this because she probably didn't start
at 6 42. she probably was up how long
how long do you think God's emails are
there dude they are so long have you
seen have you seen the Bible man oh well
that makes sense so like she's reading
for like three hours I'm gonna give you
the cliff notes email right well here's
here's got apparently an excerpt from
God's email about another Trump and Dyke
I still think it's someone that's
[__] uh pranking her I want to send
her these emails I think it is and she
believes it from God
oh my God
oh my God okay let's listen to what God
has to say about Mitch McConnell in the
next Trump indictment what's here
another whistleblower will come forward
with proof on how names are closing and
the establishment set up January 6th to
impeach Trump and to completely remove
him from any chances to run again what I
don't know what was the left what did
she say the last time she was on I you
know it's hard to keep track truly green
it's hard to keep track of all the
emails all the emails from God but let's
continue here with this with this um
weird stuff as you looked at him
a computer
is about to surface
to show the plot to take down the
president to blame him for what they had
caused that day
are you talking about blaming your body
refutable proof
that will shred the LIE of that day in
January
so apparently the hunter Biden laptop is
gonna get out in front of a microphone
and go to the press conference say hey
the computer what is this no idea
so there's like one computer that had
all the secrets on it for January 6th
well it's God's computer oh okay okay
that makes sense because every
everything that's done illegal gets sent
on uh gets sent on the Jesus network is
that what it is well it's called the J
drive it's a Jesus Drive okay all right
it's not well I mean it could be a G
Drive could be yeah yeah but that's I'm
trying to find the other video that that
she made well let's see what she says
about glitchy Mitchy because she
apparently she mentions uh Mitch
McConnell in this video 2021 uh-huh
a senator is about to have a massive
heart attack and it will surprise you on
who it really is
McConnell
another indictment against my David will
be announced but yet another one will
fail
okay so my David when God in these
emails is referring to my David
apparently he's referring to Trump
when when God
okay all right let's keep going
none of these attempts to stop him or
this election will prosper
and they will not
succeed
Mitch McCollum here we go McConnell is
about to be exposed yeah in a major way
exposed for what that he can't put a
sentence together I don't know that's
the end of the video I don't have any
other information about that maybe okay
hold on maybe she is a prophet
I'm just I mean just here just just here
just just hear me out for a sec
maybe she is a prophet okay if she's a
[__] Prophet if she's a [__]
Prophet then I'm 6'3 215 pounds okay I
mean you might be I've never seen you in
person so you very well might be two
fifteen six three but I'm just saying if
the fact that she called when did she
make that video and when did he have
that glitch that's what I want to know
um well I mean the date on the date on
this thing is um August 30th
um it might be 29th there
maybe 20. no no this says Senator Mitch
McConnell appearing to have another
scary episode in the media game yeah but
I'm telling you today look at
look at [__] look at the goddamn
calendar behind her man oh yeah yeah
yeah okay see I'm not going off of data
when it was posted I'm going off the
date she has on her account yeah which
means she's a [__] Prophet she said
this yesterday she said this yesterday
in the Mitch McConnell video came out
this morning these are emails from God
these are emails from God folks we just
uncovered sir she's she is I'm sorry she
is a prophet
I know you can't you can't tell me
otherwise now I have to believe that if
she made this on the 29th and he had
this little glitch out on the 30th oh
[__]
it's it's God speaking for sure look
everyone everyone bow down to Prophet
Julie she didn't see the Discord right
now these [__] are off the chain over
there you I'm just saying
y'all y'all in the Discord chat you do
need some Jesus over there you all need
some [__] G and you need the god
Prophet you need to be listening to her
you need God emails from God over there
they're [__] hilarious
oh my God if you want to get on the
Discord chat don't forget it's 24 7 over
there it's where the chat party never
stops you know the good part about the
Discord chat Gabe Sanchez
you know the best part about it you can
put like all kinds of [__] in there you
put gifts memes is that just instead of
just typing it in in emojis you can do
all kinds of so I put the Discord Link
in the chat below make sure to go to the
Discord join the Discord make sure to
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
right here on YouTube hit the [__]
like button if you don't like it fine
whatever hit the dislike button too
that's fine by me okay that's fine hit
the dislike button too but go to the
Tony michaels.com follow us everywhere
watch us on Twitch Facebook
um Twitter if you want if it's still
around tomorrow you can watch us
everywhere just go to the Tony
michaels.com do me a favor and go to the
Tony michaels.com click the Gabe Sanchez
merch button it'll take you to his link
tree or go to what was thatshow.com
or patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez uh the
Giuliani one was perfect my friend
perfect timing uh perfect jokes perfect
execution on the what was that beautiful
so go support Gabe's what was that
content on his patreon that's
patreon.com slash I am Gabe Sanchez I
was supposed to have a tendency Brando
on today and I forgot to mention this
earlier now he had an emergency a family
emergency and he couldn't be on today
um so I I think I'm hoping everything's
gonna be fine it's not him
um but uh I'm gonna get Tennessee Brando
back on because we're going to talk
about this Oliver Anthony thing as soon
as he can but we weren't able to get him
on today but tomorrow we'll try to go
through the Tennessee uh story of
Cameron Sexton pushing and shoving uh
Justin Pearson on the floor and all the
stuff that's happening there so stay
tuned tomorrow same time same place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon
that's one of my thoughts about what
running for re-election in 2026.
that's true
did you hear the question Senator
running for reelection in 2026
all right I'm sorry you all we're gonna
need a minute
okay okay